ah bon vous avez vu le titre vous savez
être qu'on va parler on va parler
aujourd'hui de ce produit là c'est la
surface duo microsoft surface du
hollands microsoft surface duo voulait
présenté il ya quelques jours je les
aime boxer j'ai ouvert je la regardais
j'aime beaucoup le système de charnières
qui espère vraiment leur robustesse sauf
que l'idée fashionnement très
intéressante et ça je vous le dis déjà
lors de la présentation le fait que vous
ayez un produit fermé vous puissiez
ouvrir aux mains d'un côté le maître
comme vous voulez il ya beaucoup de
configuration ça c'est super intéressant
alors 7 microsoft surface bio elle est
bien par le point de l'innovation par le
point de la recherche de microsoft pas
fait de la finesse est extrêmement fin
par le fait de chercher des solutions
alternatives et à se différencier et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'apprécie
beaucoup
avec microsoft et notamment au travers
de ce produit au travers beaucoup de
produits de microsoft
que ce soit du casque soit des
ordinateurs ils cherchent à se
différencier pour ne pas avoir toujours
la même solution que les autres
concurrents proposent pour vraiment
proposer quelque chose de différent et
d'alternatives donc ça c'est intéressant
ça veut dire que ça passe pas des
solutions complètes ça passe par des
réflexions au niveau de la conception au
niveau du produit au niveau de l' usage
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire est acquise
des styles et c'est justement là où je
pense que le bât blesse
avec ce produit là c'est sûr la cible à
qui est destiné ce produit à quoi est-ce
qu'il va ça revient parce que c'est
réellement ça se produit il me plaît de
par l'innovation et de par l'intention
mais je suis déçu par la finalisation je
suis déçu pas par la conception mais je
suis déçu parce que je veux pouvoir en
faire à laurianne il ya plein de bugs la
droite à gauche on peut dire que les
blogs logiciels saas corriger ça encore
c'est pas très grave
et j'imagine que microsoft travaille
dessus mais là où est le problème c'est
qu est ce que je vais faire de ce
produit je crois que c'est vraiment ça
qu'il faut se dire qu'est ce que je vais
faire ce produit alors je peux me dire
j'en fais plein de choses j'ai un double
écran d'un côté je mets ça de l'autre
côté je mets ça ok ça c'est ce qu'on me
racontait même si je trouve l'histoire
séduisante dans la réalité ces passages
dans des usagers je pense dans les
usages de beaucoup de monde c'est pas ça
d'où les problématiques de à qui se
produisent destine
et pour en faire quoi parce que on a
deux types de personnes on va identifier
d'un côté ce qu'on appellera le bitoux
si c'est à dire un produit qui va se
vendre à des consommateurs notamment
grand public et de l'autre côté ce qu'on
appellera le 'b to b' c'est à dire des
produits qui s'adresse à des
professionnels quelles que soient leurs
métiers du tertiaire de
bref peu importe première usages c'est
sur le [ __ ] ou si c'est à dire sur le
grand public le grand public pour moi ce
produit tu peux pas fonctionner il peut
pas fonctionner pour plusieurs points
les usages tels qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
les usages sont veut un produit sympa un
produit différent si on veut pouvoir
téléphoner avec pourquoi pas déjà moyens
premier truc qui me pose problème là
dessus c'est pour téléphoner c'est la
prise en main il est extrêmement large
lorsque vous voulez un smartphone eh
bien on 28 qui tiennent bien dans la
paume de votre main qu'on puisse glisser
facilement voiliers sont vraiment avoir
à galérer ce produit là il est très
large il est vraiment très large donc
bon après vous me direz ça c'est du pin
détails je chipote d'accord avec vous on
peut néanmoins se poser passer un coup
de fil
bon ça serait il est large mais c'est
pas vraiment le principal problème même
si microsoft ne définit pas comme étant
le téléphone pour moi c'est un téléphone
qui se plissent est un hybride entre une
tablette un téléphone mais c'est un
usage principal c'est le téléphone même
si on est sur un outil pour la
productivité on le comprend mais usage
ça va être naviguer sur les réseaux
sociaux ça va être allé sur instagram ça
va être aller sur facebook ça va être
allé regarder des films des séries alors
lorsque je navigue et bien je dirais que
l'inconvénient qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver c'est qu'effectivement ici on
n'a pas un seul l'année grand écran on a
un écran qui casse et au milieu qu'on a
deux écrans séparés et cette coupure on
la voit et c'est très inconfortable
lorsque vous êtes sur l'instinct g et
que vous naviguez c'est très
inconfortable lorsqu'on est sur facebook
et que vous naviguez c'est inconfortable
lorsque vous venez naviguer sur une page
web même fou ça assez inconfortable en
grand écran et effectivement si vous
venez c'est pareil d'un côté vous mettez
instagram le côté vous mettez je ne sais
pas quoi on peut le faire mais c'est pas
réellement ce qu'on attend ce qu'on
attend c'est pouvoir utiliser ce grand
écran dans le point c'est je viens de
regarder un film ou une série il fait
plus le bât blesse je me dirais ok je
vais un film d'un côté je me mets un
message genre de l'autre côté ça ne
marche pas d'un point de vue logiciel
d'un point de vue intégration alors on
peut se dire une fois de plus ça ça peut
être corrigée je suis d'accord ça peut
être corrigé les éditeurs peuvent
travailler dessus microsoft peut
travailler sur l'expérience mais
aujourd'hui quand se produit sort on se
retrouve avec quelque chose qui n'est
pas suffisamment abouti qui n'est pas
suffisamment je pense réfléchi sur ces
questions d' usage et qui du coup ne
fonctionne pas autres usages très
important pour le grand public ça va
être le gaming
aujourd'hui le gaming sur smartphone on
retrouve deux partout et ça reste un
usage extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement répandu et très très très
important sauf que là je vais vous faire
ne serait ce qu'une partie de ce fait
neuf et bien vous retrouver cette espèce
de coupures au milieu au niveau de votre
écran vous n'avez pas accès à tous les
boutons pour bien choisir votre
direction ça ne va pas c'est pas
pratique
donc une fois de plus
m d'intégration logicielle on pourrait
s'attendre à se dire c'est intéressant
comme nintendo 3ds loyer qu'ils se
pliaient à l'écran sur le haut sur le
baiia les éditeurs viennent vraiment
optimisé leur jeu pour cette solution ok
sauf qu'aujourd'hui ça la microsoft
surface duo ça représente pas énormément
de ventes pour sa part présenté beaucoup
de ventes
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'un éditeur irait
travailler venir adapter un jeu pour
cette solution là qui reste très riche
et non voilà ça c'est pareil j'y crois
pas donc venir jouer sur le double écran
ça marche pas y avoir une certaine duo
pour jouer uniquement sur l'écran du
haut de l'écran du bas bah ça reste
extrêmement frustrant et ça non plus ça
fonctionne pas autres usages très très
important c'est la partie photo et
là-dessus microsoft n'a pas du tout été
bon sur la partie photo une fois de plus
dans l'idée de la productivité en se
disant at on besoin d'un appareil photo
là-dessus essayer ça et je m'en suis
rendu compte en fait vraiment leur donne
donc si je me mets pas rendu compte
avant vous n'avez qu'une seule caméra
ici sur le dessus vous n'avez aucune
caméra ce soit à l'arrière que ce soit
partout vous n'allez pas vous n'avez
qu'une caméra ici est en fait la
problématique et ça je dois déjà
expliqué également pour venir
aujourd'hui avoir des optiques en 2021
sur un smartphone sur une tablette aux
sources que vous voulez et bien on vient
rajouter des couches au niveau de
l'optique pour réussir à voir quelque
chose qui fonctionne et qui rentre dans
un smartphone et avoir une bonne qualité
ce qui fait que si vous voulez quelque
chose qui est plat aujourd'hui qui est
tout petit et qui rentre dans une
solution de smartphone ordinateur ou
tablette
il ya vous devez faire vraiment des
compromis en terme d'optimum et faire
des compromis et vous n'aurez pas de
bonne qualité on n'a pas de qualité de
d'appareils photo telle qu'on peut
s'attendre à lavaur en tout cas sur un
smartphone et sur un smartphone à 1500
euros sur un produit en tout cas 1500
euros même si on vient pas le
catégoriser dans les smartphones donc ça
une fois de plus en termes d'attenté en
termes d' usage c'est extrêmement
décevant alors c'est pas mal si vous
voulez travailler à faire une conf avec
tim sous skype ou ce que vous voulez ça
fonctionnera sur une fois de plus du
lien notamment dans lequel duco vite
comme ça reste en lien avec des
collègues reste en lien avec de la
famille ça fonctionne donc pour tous
qu'il est grand public
ça fonctionne pas et cette surface du
hall est pas bonne si vous n'en avez pas
un usage professionnel je vois pas
pourquoi vous auriez acheté ce produit
mise à part et mais l'innovation mise à
part avoir un produit très différents
mais à partir de très fins et venir dire
aux copains la neige un truc est
différent c'est microsoft vous n'avez
pas la même chose que moi voilà mais
au-delà de ça il ya un moment ça qu'on
sera vraiment par rapport à l'eigerjoch
après ça c'est les agents publics
maintenant vous avez les usages
professionnels alors on sait que
derrière tout professionnel on retrouve
quelques rues du grand public parce que
il a une vie
pour regarder du contenu parce qu'il
veut faire des photos parce qu'il veut
pouvoir jouer mais si on se ressente
vraiment que sur les usages
professionnels
eh bien on peut se dire que c'est
intéressant pour venir collaborer alors
moi ce que je trouve intéressant ici
c'est effectivement le fait d'avoir mon
outlook de retrouver sur la partie de
gauche par exemple sur les emails et
bien la liste de mes e-mails sur la
partie droite venir consulter les lire
mais email ça fonctionne c'est
intéressant pour voir venir faire du
multitâche avec de l'autre côté une
navigation sur internet et de l'autre
côté je peux avoir un outil pour venir à
voir de la productivité avoir un
powerpoint avoir un excellent avoir un
world bon ça fonctionnera mais ça ça
fonctionnera vraiment dans l'idée du
multitâche dans l'idée d'avoir un écran
dédié à une application professionnelle
pour pouvoir faire du reporting sacrées
bonnes choses comme ça donc c'est
vraiment ça qui vient aujourd'hui d'être
intéressant mais au-delà de cet usage
qui restent les usages très vite oui non
je bats je reste vraiment très très très
très dubitatif
lui encore là je vous présente deux
solutions qui sont vraiment adapté un
complètement adapté pour microsoft mais
voilà pour moi c'est du mal j'ai
vraiment du mal à comprendre ce qu'ils
ont voulu faire là dessus
donc ça veut dire que si je veux gérer
une to do list si je pouvoir gérer des
email si je vais avoir un logiciel word
si je veux avoir un excellent si je veux
avoir un powerpoint si je vais avoir un
team ce ça fonctionnera mais pour tout
le reste c'est un produit qu'il faut
oublier et tout le reste ça représente
tellement mais tellement que ça c'est
dommage
et ça ça coûte plus de 1500 euros et
quand je dis ça je veux pas dénigrer le
produit parce que j'aime innovation la
charnière je trouve vraiment canon la
finesse je trouve vraiment top
sauf que microsoft a soit été trop vite
en disant il faut sortir se produit
rapidement pour faire parler parce que
relais dans le moment duplicable et du
coup ils ont bâclé un petit peu tout
cette question de répondre à une
problématique ou vraiment venir adresser
ce produit est une cible très précise ou
alors ils n'ont pas été assez vite parce
que c'est un produit qu'ils auraient dû
sortir fin 2010 9 début 2020 quand il a
été présenté en a commencé en parlait
déjà il ya très longtemps de ce produit
là et à ce moment là après la
présentation
ils auraient dû être présentés c'est
pareil vous avez un qualcomm snapdragon
855 qui n'est pas la dernière génération
alors c'est normal parce que c'est un
produit qui a quand même deux ans donc
vous avez aujourd'hui sur un produit qui
va le sortir en europe en 2021 et bien
un processeur qui a deux ans qu'ils ont
des problématiques une fois de plus se
reproduit à 1500 euros alors pour usage
professionnel ça fonctionnera sa
dragonne 155
il fonctionne bien je veux pas dire
qu'il fonctionne pas il fonctionne très
bien
une fois de plus à 1500 euros voyez ça
ça fait un petit peu râlé autre chose
qui me fait râler c'est que même si vous
êtes sur un usage professionnel et bien
si vous n'avez pas de 5g vous n'avez pas
de modèle 5 j'ai intégré c'est aussi
problématique j'ai notamment pour les
usages professionnels si moi je suis un
professionnel sur un déplacement et je
veux que ça aille vite je veux de la
saint jean
si je peux par l'a5 si j'aurais pas de
5g une fois de plus 1500 euros en
perspective par rapport à ce qui existe
sur le marché et par rapport aux
différents outils qu'on peut avoir
ça fonctionne pas non plus vous n'avez
pas non plus de nfc pas de paiement
dématérialisé tous les usages qu'on peut
imaginer avec le nfc aussi la charge est
très longue il faut vraiment bien vous
armer de patience pour venir leur charge
et l'autonomie est pas non plus
exceptionnel si vous tenez une journée
vous êtes content donc voyez pour mille
soit 149 euros et cumule trop de points
négatifs pour réussir à venir
le recommander à trouver ce produit
suffisamment intéressante moi j'étais
vraiment intéressé mais vraiment
intéressés par ce produit en me disant
c'est différent c'est vraiment différent
et on comprend que microsoft dans l'
usage pro dont l'âge de la productivité
on va avoir quelque chose d'intéressant
tu vraiment bien réfléchir vraiment bien
conceptualiser et tout ça en l'alliant
bien évidemment aux problématiques du
grand public et ben flat pour moi on
répond un peu aux usages professionnels
mais on oublie tellement on oublie
tellement que voilà je suis assez déçu
de ce produit je continue à dire j'aime
microsoft james qui propose les
innovations les différentes surfaces en
dehors de ce produit là je trouve
intéressant il faut que sur l'audio il
progresse aussi vachement bien il ya
plein de belles solutions
c'est vraiment une boîte qui a beaucoup
d'innovations qui cherchent à se
différencier une fois de plus et ça
change vraiment a souligné j'aime
beaucoup mais ça non c'est microsoft
c'est tellement dommage c'est tellement
dommage quand on sent plus le passif qui
a avec le smartphone où on sait que
microsoft s'était déjà mangé dans
l'univers du smartphone là ils
reviennent avec un produit qui même
s'ils n'annoncent pas comme étant un
smartphone on est sur un hybride mais
quand même accès smartphones plus plus
plus et ça va être bon une fois de plus
son chemin c'est vrai je suis très
endettés les dédommagements